[Music]
that's my phone which is also essential
but not one of the top 10.
what's up gq this is jonathan majors and
these
are my 10 essentials
[Applause]
first we're gonna start with
this guy i know what you're thinking
it's just a beanie
correct it's just a beanie in fact i
bought this beanie on the side of the
road
in harlem 125th street it's red which is
my favorite color
and you can do this with this beanie
[Music]
and be seen by everybody when you're on
your bike
in new york city speeding down the road
trying not to die
i'm your man in the red beginning it's
okay that's jay i got you
pocket knife it's actually a shinola
pocket knife and it is the first pocket
knife i bought myself
as an adult male it's not to be tough or
anything it's actually just to open up
uh
anything you know you open up your fedex
boxes
open up your daughter's candy
let me just say this once and for all
you do not ask
someone to borrow their pocket knife
it's kind of like
if you smoke you should have your own
lighter
you didn't need the pocket knife until
you saw i had the pocket knife
get yourself a pocket knife friend
respectfully
mountain valley spring water
what can i what it's water
from heaven room temp i've been told
is the way it should be but i grew up in
texas and
uh hot day cold water that just makes
sense to me i don't understand the
science of it
uh apparently it's bad for you but i
lived in that state for 18 years and
made it out just fine so
you know it's an elixir for help
[Music]
this is made by an artisan somebody sat
down and with their
mind and energy and focus crafted this
particular cup i don't know if you can
see
but it's it's actually not even at all
and i wanted to go with this one because
it had the most
personality it had the most
imperfections it just became a thing
for me to always have my own vessel
uh to kind of move through the world
with and this
is made of a particular clay that
actually holds
the taste and the smell and the essence
of the beverage you had last
and i just found it neat and it's kind
of a comfort thing you know okay let's
see
i had matcha tea this morning and then
i didn't actually but let's just go with
it right actually no let's do it
like oh no last thing in here was matcha
t
this revolve plus bose speaker
i
if there was one essential
i love the hat love the cup
need the knife but this bose speaker
can you curse on here cause this
[ __ ] right here
this right here is the day-to-day
save you change your mood get you ready
get you undone concoction this thing
is incredible and i'm proud of this one
because
it actually has dirt on it
from a field that me and my partners
uh work out in does this have a handle
girl yes it has a handle you use the
handle
to hang it in your shower right because
it's waterproof
these should be given to the military
[Music]
here's an essential for you warrior of
the light
a manual by paulo callow there's like a
subtitle short
notes on accepting failure embracing
life
and rising to your destiny i mean this
book is also
torn to [ __ ] this book has seen many
countries
and looks like many raspberries it's a
secular
teaching you know with spiritual accents
i also hand it out to people take a
picture of a passage and send it off to
a buddy
or a friend or a student of mine and say
hey check this out
watch this this is at random
okay i'll just read you any passage this
is the first teaching of the nights
you will erase everything you had
written in the book of your life
up until now restlessness uncertainty
lies and in the place of all this you
will write the word
courage by beginning the journey with
that word
and continuing with faith in god you
will arrive
wherever you need to arrive that's it
randa
p.s my favorite word of all time in any
language
is courage
[Music]
i won't keep it on for long but that's a
red nose
[Music]
all right now the reason i took it off
so quickly is that there's rules
to this note this nose in particular
comes from a magician
and he teaches clown is something that
you get
from him after a certain amount of
semesters of training
it also represents the most amount of
freedom i've ever experienced in my life
my understanding and my belief is that
the clown is connected to
the most innocent part of us and that
innocent part of us
is a unsocialized body i've had this
for five years and have missed flights
behind it have gotten to the airport
checked my bag and been like nope we
gotta go back
literally we have to go back you sure
sir don't [ __ ] with me we're going back
and we're gonna get this notes
jmm sunglasses
these sunglasses are in my opinion
the most dope um sunglasses i've ever
experienced each
pair of glasses is designed and inspired
by
essentially icons so for instance
these at random
uh sturgis sturgis developed a
reputation for a lifetime of
contribution
in an edgy update of spectacles worn by
acclaimed director
john sturgis known for directing
psychological
westerns and war films like the
magnificent seven and the great escape
come on okay also these are number 70
of 450. i i have become hooked
and here's another pair
yep you know it's a piece of art
very much like uh the aforementioned
cup it has value in ways that aren't
monetary
and i appreciate that and then i checked
the specs where they made
blah blah blah oh that's great and it
holds up
the next item these jeans here
quite simple they're louis vuitton
and you wouldn't guess it you wouldn't
guess it these are just good old cowboy
jeans and i keep them cuffed um
like a good texan i keep them on my
waist
uh like my mama taught me and they are
the most
comfortable most versatile i've owned i
think
here's the thing i don't wash them
ever you know they're jeans if you want
to dress up
dress up they're made to be rough
roughhoused and
and all those things the best compliment
you can get in your jeans are
oh your legs are good today or oh
nice shoes that's a good one oh nice
shoes which means everything you got
going on
has brought their attention to your boot
game or to whatever shoes you wear
we'll talk about that in a second cause
i have a pair there that i wear quite
often
[Music]
these are my tennies these are my tennis
shoes
no shame these were given to me and i
have not taken them off
since i grew up in converse reeboks
payless and the plethora of the payless
genre
which i thank you very much for getting
me through elementary school
and junior high school but then i got
these and what i liked about these the
most is that
they came kind of pre-pre-scuffed
they have proper creases um they have
the
[Music]
everybody knows what i mean when i go
which means tied or untied you can just
and you're good to go don't act like you
don't know what i mean if you don't know
what i mean you need better shoes
[Music]
here it is dr dennis gross
alpha beta extra strength
daily pill now we're just going to
demonstrate
i don't i don't know any other way to do
it so it's quite simple you take them
out
uh you do it so you just wipe right it's
an exfoliant
it exfoliates exfoliate what's that mean
g
what it means is it begins to turn over
the dead cells on your skin
because the dead skin clogs the pores
allows oil to build up you know what's
not gangsta
pimples you see that you maybe you can't
right but that's real the second one is
an anti-aging
neutralizer i don't know what the [ __ ]
that means
anti-aging neutralizer but i do know
what it does and i highly recommend it
you just hit it again a second time you
can hit your lips
you can go you can get in your beard
whatever beard
[Music]
we're done we've done it i did it thank
you very much thanks for watching
these are my 10 essentials peace